PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
GINA LOST HER NERVE
UNDER THE SPOTLIGHT.
I'M KIND OF, LIKE,
HAVING AN IDENTITY CRISIS HERE.
AND JADE PUSHED HER
OVER THE EDGE.
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION,
YOU GOTTA KNOW WHO YOU ARE--
PERIOD.
THEN BALD WAS BEAUTIFUL
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT...
THIS IS FIERCE.
FOR SOME MORE
THAN OTHERS.
I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS DOING.
UGH!
FURONDA.
AND WHEN THE JUDGES
COULDN'T SEE A TOP MODEL
IN OUR SOUTHERN BELLE,
KATHY WAS SENT HOME.
12 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED
TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
♪I WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪♪
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
UNDERSTAND?
READ IT.
"THINK ABOUT TONIGHT'S CUT
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE MORE
AT 7:30 A.M."
OH!
I WAS--MY HEART WAS BEATING
SO FAST THAT IT FELT LIKE
IT WAS, LIKE, IN MY NECK.
NIGEL WAS KIND OF INSINUATING
THAT I WAS ARROGANT.
I'M VERY HUMBLE,
I'M VERY DOWN TO EARTH.
WELL, WHAT I WAS
ABOUT TO SAY--
PART OF BEING HUMBLE
IS ABOUT BEING QUIET--
WELL, HUMBLE INSIDE, I MEAN.
AND LISTENING--
NIGEL, I MEAN HUMBLE INSIDE,
NOT--I'M NOT QUIET.
AND NOT TALKING
OVER THE JUDGES.
EVERYBODY THAT KNOWS ME
KNOWS I'M JUST
THIS DOWN-TO-EARTH PERSON.
I JUST WISH THAT PEOPLE SEE
WHO JADE REALLY IS.
IT'S CRAZY.
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE
HOW NERVE-RACKING IT IS.
I BELIEVE IN KARMA.
CONSIDERING THAT JADE
HAS BEEN NOT-SO-KIND TO ME...
TO BE IN THIS COMPETITION,
YOU KNOW, YOU GOTTA KNOW
WHO YOU ARE--PERIOD.
THE JUDGES TOLD HER
THAT SHE'S ARROGANT.
SHE REALLY DESERVED IT.
GINA HAS A LOT OF PROBLEMS,
DUDE,
LIKE, PERSONAL PROBLEMS WITHIN
HERSELF.
IT SHOWS.
YOU'RE IN A COMPETITION.
YOU CAN'T
BE WEAK-MINDED.
I THINK YOU WERE
A LITTLE HARSH WITH HER.
I WAS JUST, LIKE, DAMN.
JADE--I KNOW WHAT TYPE
OF PERSON SHE IS.
IF SHE FEELS LIKE SHE'S FOUND
AN EASY TARGET,
SHE WORKS WITH IT.
NOBODY'S GONNA WANT
A WEAK AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'M AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE BARREL.
YOU NEED TO KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE AT THE BOTTOM
OF THIS HEAP.
BUT I'M NOT SCARED OF JADE
'CAUSE IF SHE COMES OVER THERE
WITH SILLINESS,
THEN I'M GONNA DEAL WITH IT.
HOPEFULLY, THIS WILL BE
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
OH, HELL,
IT TOTALLY IS, MAN.
LIFE IS JUST
A LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
♪♪♪
SOMETIMES I'LL, LIKE,
LOOK OVER AT YOU,
AND YOU'RE, LIKE, ZONED OUT.
RIGHT NOW, I THINK
IT'S KIND OF HARD.
I'M SLOWLY REPEATING OVER
EVERYTHING FROM NEW ORLEANS.
I DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE MY PARENTS WERE.
THEY WERE TRYING TO EVACUATE,
AND THEY JUST SLEPT IN A CAR
FOR, LIKE, TWO DAYS,
AND THAT WAS THE LAST TIME
I TALKED TO THEM.
SORRY.
THAT WAS, LIKE,
NERVE-RACKING.
BUT, FINALLY, WE GOT IN TOUCH.
WENDY DEFINITELY
SEEMS DISTRACTED,
OFF IN HER LITTLE WORLD.
SHE HAS A LOT OF THINGS
OCCUPYING HER MIND.
♪♪♪
HELLO.
HI.
YOU'RE IN ONE
OF THE BEST SALONS
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD--
THE WARREN-TRICOMI SALON.
TODAY IS A DAY
OF TRANSFORMATION.
I NEED LONG HAIR
BECAUSE I KNOW IN THE INDUSTRY,
LONG HAIR IS WHAT SELLS.
AND AFTER YOUR MAKEOVERS,
YOU ALL WILL BE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT
TO CAPTURE YOUR NEW LOOKS.
I AM GOING TO INTRODUCE
THE MASTERS.
FIRST IS JOEL WARREN.
JOEL IS
THE MASTER OF COLOR.
AND EDWARD TRICOMI
IS THE MASTER OF THE CUT.
WE CALL HIM EDWARD SCISSORHANDS.
ARE YOU READY TO HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA GET?
YES.
ALL RIGHTY.
STARTING WITH YOU, KARI,
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
BRIGITTE BARDOT SEXY HAIR.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE MINE,
BUT EVEN BIGGER.
LESLIE, WE FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE A LATINA STUNNER, BABY.
SO IT'S GONNA BE THICKER
AND MORE LUSCIOUS.
SARA, WE DIDN'T KNOW
HOW MUCH FACE YOU HAD, GIRL,
UNTIL WE SAW
THAT BALD PHOTO SHOOT.
IT'S GONNA BE SHORT ON THE SIDES
AND LONGER ON THE TOP.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE
BRIGITTE NIELSEN
PLATINUM BLONDE, ALL RIGHT?
I AM IMMEDIATELY SHOCKED
BECAUSE IT'S NOTHING LIKE
MY PERSONAL STYLE.
DANIELLE, YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
A SIDE PART, LONG WEAVE
WITH SPANISH WAVY HAIR.
OKAY, OKAY.
BROOKE, WHEN WE LOOK AT YOU,
WE THINK VICTORIA'S SECRET.
WE THINK HIGH-FASHION.
SO YOU KNOW WHOSE HAIR
YOU'RE GONNA GET?
MINE.
YOU'RE GONNA GET
MISS GISELE BUNDCHEN-HAIR, BABY.
WOW, I'M--YEAH.
JOANIE, WE'RE GONNA DO
A LITTLE BIT MORE BLONDE ON YOU
AND MAKE YOU
A LITTLE BIT MORE ICY.
OKAY.
NNENNA, WE WERE ALL IMPRESSED
WITH THAT BALD PHOTO SHOOT.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA GET?
(buzzing noise)
BUZZED.
ALL YOUR HAIR--GONE.
FURONDA, THAT HAIR, CHILD,
THAT CASTING WITH THAT WIG ON.
WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?
AND IN JUDGING THE OTHER NIGHT,
ONE OF OUR FAVORITE HAIR STYLES
OF THE HISTORY
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS TIFFANY, CYCLE 4,
WHEN SHE HAD A MIDDLE PART
DOWN TO HERE.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GETTING
TODAY.
I'M READY FOR THE MAKEOVER.
I NEEDED TO BOOST MYSELF UP
AND HAVE POSITIVE ENERGY
SO THAT I CAN PERFORM.
WENDY, WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
LIGHTER, BRIGHTER, HONEY,
DELICIOUS.
GINA, WE'RE GONNA GIVE
SOME EDGY CUTS AND ANGLES
TO YOUR HAIR
TO MAKE YOU MORE HIGH-FASHION
AND LESS, "OH, MY GOD.
I WANT TO BUY
A CUTE DENIM SKIRT."
ALL RIGHT?
MISS MOLLIE SUE,
IF YOU THINK BACK TO CYCLE 5
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
WHEN I WANTED CASSANDRA TO HAVE
A MIA FARROW HAIRCUT...
I'M NOT HAPPY WITH IT,
I'LL BE HONEST,
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
THE HAIR STYLE
THAT I TOLD HIM TO GIVE YOU.
I SPECIFICALLY SAID,
"MIA FARROW
IN 'ROSEMARY'S BABY.'"
SO YOU'RE NOT READY
TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
NO.
YOU JUST GOTTA LEAVE MY SET,
OKAY?
I NEVER GOT TO GET
MY MIA FARROW HAIRCUT.
SO I'M GETTIN' IT TODAY ON YOU!
AND LAST, BUT NOT LEAST, JADE,
WE WANT TO MAKE YOU LOOK SOFTER,
SWEETER, ELF-LIKE--
THIS SHORT, BLONDISH
WITH BLONDISH EYEBROWS.
I WAS REALLY SHOCKED
ABOUT THAT.
MY HAIR IS--IT'S GOING.
IT FREAKED ME OUT.
ARE YOU READY TO DO THIS?
YEAH!
ALL RIGHTY,
ONE, TWO, THREE... LET'S GO!
A LOT OF GIRLS
WHEN THEY START MODELING,
YOU KNOW, THEY HAD THIS HAIR
FROM WHEN THEY WERE A KID.
WHEN YOU'RE A MODEL,
EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING GOES.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE
GONNA GIVE ME EXTENSIONS
BUT CHANGE MY COLOR
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
IN MODELING--THE MODELING WORLD,
THE GIRLS THAT WORK
HAVE THE LONG HAIR.
THIS WAS A DISASTER HAIRCUT,
AND I NEED SOMETHING
TO BE CONFIDENT ABOUT
SO THAT IT CAN SHOW.
♪♪♪
WHY?
I DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY'RE LEAVING MY TOP
LONGER THAN MY SIDES.
JADE, JUST SHUT UP.
ANTONIO WAS, LIKE,
WE'RE GONNA CUT THIS SHORT
AND LEAVE THIS HIGH.
OH, GREAT,
ANOTHER, LIKE, MOHAWK LOOK.
OH, MY GOSH.
SHUT UP.
SARA.
SHE LOOKS A LOT BETTER.
OH, MY GOD,
I LOVE THAT.
SARA GETS THIS CRAZY,
FUNKY HAIRCUT
THAT JUST DIDN'T REALLY FIT
HER PERSONALITY,
AND SHE REALLY
TOOK IT NOT GOOD.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU CAN DO
A LOT ABOUT THAT.
A LOT.
WHICH IS GOOD.
I WANT YOU TO DEFINE FOR US
WHAT YOU THINK
YOUR PERSONAL STYLE IS.
I LIKE VINTAGE A LOT.
SO YOU'RE A LATE '40s,
EARLY '50s VINTAGE GIRL.
THIS IS, LIKE,
THE MOST DRASTIC CHANGE
I'VE EVER HAD.
I LIKE IT.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THE COLOR.
I THINK IT SUITS ME.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK
YOUR PERSONAL STYLE IS.
I THINK IT'S SIMPLE
AND SOPHISTICATED.
I'VE ALWAYS HAD
STRAIGHT BLACK HAIR.
I WANTED SOMETHING DRASTIC--
BIG, POOFY CURLS
OR JUST SOMETHING,
BUT IT'S FINE.
THIS IS GREAT.
I'M REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT MY NEW LOOK.
I THINK IT'S GONNA WORK
REALLY, REALLY WELL.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO A VERY
UPDATED VERSION OF MOD.
YEAH.
DO YOU THINK
YOU COULD DO THAT?
I COULD DO THAT.
WHO IS FURONDA?
IT'S REALLY A SIMPLE CUT.
SOMETIMES,
IT'S KIND OF QUIRKY.
SO FURONDA'S
THE QUIRKY BEAUTIFUL.
MAKEOVER DAY
IS A GODSEND.
THE HAIR IS REALLY VERSATILE,
AND IT'LL GIVE ME
A LOT MORE TO WORK WITH
WITH MY LOOK.
I REALLY LIKE THE '60s.
I THINK THEY KIND OF WENT
WITH THE '60s.
SO, LIKE, BOHEMIAN CHIC?
YEAH.
I WAS HOPING
FOR MAYBE DARKER OR SHORTER.
I DO NOT WANT TO LOOK
LIKE BARBIE,
BUT I'LL HAVE TO ROCK IT.
I WANT TO BE UNIQUE
AND MORE NATURAL.
I'LL CALL IT
THE NEW AFRICAN QUEEN.
I THINK THIS BALD LOOK
HELPS EMPOWER ME MORE.
I JUST HAVE TO WORK IT
A LITTLE HARDER
'CAUSE I DON'T HAVE ANY HAIR
TO HIDE BEHIND.
WHO IS SARA NOW?
SARA'S A LOT EDGIER
THAN SHE USED TO BE.
LIKE, STREET CHIC?
I HAVE TO REDO
MY WHOLE WARDROBE.
I WAS FREAKING OUT IN THE CHAIR.
IT JUST DIDN'T SEEM TO FIT
MY PERSONALITY.
I'M ALREADY GETTING
MORE USED TO IT.
BUT I WAS NOT GONNA BE
THE GIRL IN THE SALON
CRYING ABOUT HER NEW MAKEOVER.
I THINK RIGHT NOW,
IT'S VERY AMERICAN.
YOU DEFINE IT FOR ME
AS THE ALL-AMERICAN GIRL.
ALL-AMERICAN GIRL.
I LOVE MY MAKEOVER,
AND I THINK IT ALSO REALLY
GIVES ME A LOT MORE,
LIKE, CONFIDENCE.
I THINK WITH THE HAIR
AND EVERYTHING,
I JUST THINK, LIKE, SEXY.
UNDERSTATED SEXY--
SIMPLISTIC, SEXY CHIC.
I JUST WANT TO, LIKE,
SWING IT AROUND
AND PLAY WITH IT,
AND I LOVE IT.
I'M THINKING SWEET-FACED.
J.LO.
URBAN GLAM.
I LIKE THE HAIR, AND IT'S EASIER
FOR ME TO KEEP UP.
SO IT MADE ME FEEL A LOT BETTER.
WITH THE HAIR,
WITH THE NEW LOOK,
I'M THINKING REALLY SEXY,
GLAMOROUS.
STREET CHIC, BUT GLAMOROUS--
RIGHT THERE.
HIP-HOP GLAM.
I HAD
THIS LONG RAPUNZEL HAIR.
IT'S A TRIP.
NICE, GOOD.
RIGHT THERE.
I THINK YOU'RE LIKE
THAT FASHIONISTA GIRL.
NOT REALLY,
I'M MORE BOHEMIAN.
YOU THINK YOU'RE
A BOHEMIAN GIRL?
YEAH, DOWN-TO-EARTH.
BLACK PANTHER PARTY.
I'VE HAD MY HAIR
CUT REALLY SHORT,
AND I FEEL LIKE LENGTH
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA GET
LONG EXTENSIONS,
WHICH FURONDA GOT.
SO WHAT ARE WE GOIN' FOR
TODAY?
GHETTO PROJECT FABULOUS.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
DURING A MAKEOVER
FOR A GIRL TO UNDERSTAND
HER OWN PERSONAL STYLE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE GONNA CALL
THIS ONE?
WE'RE GONNA CALL THIS
THE AL SHARPTON.
OH, MY GOD,
OH, MY GOD!
I LIKE THIS MAKEOVER.
(scoffs)
J. IS GIVING YOU
A LITTLE PRECURSOR
TO TOMORROW'S CHALLENGE.
YOU GIRLS ARE ACTUALLY GONNA GO
TO THE GEN ART FASHION SHOW.
IT'S A SHOW THAT LAUNCHES
A LOT OF NEW
AND UPCOMING DESIGNERS.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR YOU GIRLS
TO FIND OUTFITS IN THAT SHOW
THAT ARE ADAPTABLE
TO THE PERSONAL STYLE
THAT YOU GUYS
TOLD US ABOUT TODAY.
ALL RIGHT, GIRLS,
WE'LL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
BYE.
LOOK WHAT'S
IN THE MAGAZINES NOW--
LONG HAIR, LONG HAIR.
JADE DIDN'T WANT TO GO SHORT.
SHE WANTED EXTENSIONS.
THE JUDGES DON'T WANT
TO MAKE IT LOOK SO EASY
BECAUSE I'M SURE THE WORD IS,
LIKE, OH, THIS GIRL--
THIS GIRL GOT SOMETHING.
LONG HAIR.
LONG HAIR, BABY.
FURONDA IS SO FEELING THIS HAIR
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN THERE'S A MIRROR ANYWHERE,
SHE'S IN IT FIXING THAT HAIR.
THAT IS A TRUE MISS DIVA.
I KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO
RIGHT NOW.
CHILL?
I'M ABOUT TO HAND OUT
MY RULES.
I HAVE A LIST OF TIPS,
JUST COMMON COURTESIES
THAT I WOULD EXPECT
FOR THE GIRLS.
(bell dings)
LADIES, HELLO.
THESE ARE TIPS.
"FURONDA'S TIPS
FOR SUCCESSFUL INTERACTION."
(bell dings)
WHAT UP?
THAT'S HILARIOUS.
(bell dings)
I GOT A COPY FOR YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GIVE HER YOURS.
FURONDA, YOU'RE A DIVA.
BUT WHY
ARE YOU DOING THIS?
BECAUSE I WANT TO--
THESE ARE THINGS
I WANTED EVERYONE TO KNOW.
IT'S YOUR COPY.
IF YOU WANT TO THROW IT AWAY,
YOU CAN THROW IT AWAY,
BUT I GAVE IT TO YOU.
ARE YOU A PRIMA DONNA?
DO YOU THINK YOU'RE QUEEN BEE
OF THE HOUSE?
I'M TELLING YOU,
THAT HAIR HAS MADE
HER CONFIDENCE LEVEL
THROUGH THE ROOF.
SHE THINKS SHE IS, LIKE,
AN IMITATION NAOMI CAMPBELL.
BUT SHE'S GOT IT ALL TWISTED.
I'M FEELING A LOT BETTER
NOW THAT MY HAIR'S DONE,
AND I'M FABULOUS
AND I'M BEAUTIFUL.
YOU CAN WEAR IT IF YOU WANT.
I WOULDN'T BE CAUGHT DEAD
WEARING THAT, SWEETHEART.
OKAY.
WHEN I CAME
INTO THIS COMPETITION,
I FELT VERY CONFIDENT,
BUT TO PULL THIS OFF--DUDE.
HEY, YOU NOTICE SOMETHING?
PEOPLE HAVE ALWAYS HATED
ABOUT ME
THE FACT THAT THEY CAN'T REALLY
GET UNDER MY SKIN.
HATE IS, LIKE,
SUCH A HARSH WORD.
I CAN SEE DISLIKING,
BUT HATE IS--WHOA.
IT COULD BE A MOHAWK,
IT COULD BE, LIKE, A BOB.
IT COULD BE, LIKE--
YEAH?
IT'S RIDICULOUS, LIKE--
YOU DON'T LIKE IT?
NO.
IT'S JUST NOT ME.
♪♪♪
WE WERE GOING
TO THE GEN ART FASHION SHOW
TO PICK AN OUTFIT
THAT WOULD MATCH
OUR PERSONAL STYLE.
♪♪♪
I KIND OF DRIFTED AWAY
FROM THE FASHION SHOW
FOR A MINUTE.
IT'S KIND OF HARD
WITH EVERYTHING GOING ON
BACK IN NEW ORLEANS.
♪♪♪
HOPEFULLY,
YOU WERE TAKING NOTICE
OF THE DESIGNS
THAT FIT YOUR PERSONAL STYLE.
NOW IN THIS CHALLENGE,
WE'RE GONNA LET YOU GIRLS
CHOOSE AMONG THE RACKS.
ALL RIGHT, READY?
GO.
♪♪♪
IT'S LIKE A SAMPLE SALE!
I WAS STILL NOT ADJUSTED
TO THE WAY I LOOKED.
I DON'T EVEN LOOK
LIKE I BELONG ON THIS PLANET.
WE CAN DO TWO, RIGHT?
AND I CAME UP
WITH A REALLY HOT OUTFIT.
I THOUGHT IT EXUDED
MY PERSONAL STYLE TO A TEE.
WE'RE ON THE STREET CHIC,
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S STREET CHIC
RIGHT HERE.
I KIND OF WAS UNSURE
OF WHAT MY STYLE REALLY WAS.
IT'S, LIKE,
SO MAYBE I COULD JUST,
LIKE, WEAR MY BRA
AND, LIKE, HOT PANTS UNDERNEATH.
ARE THESE, LIKE, HOT PANTS?
DO YOU-- YOU DON'T HAVE HOT
PANTS, OBVIOUSLY.
ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU GUYS ALL GOT AN OUTFIT?
YES.
OKAY.
THIS IS ONLY THE FIRST PART
OF THE CHALLENGE.
THE NEXT PART IS STILL AHEAD.
GOOD LUCK.
♪♪♪
HELLO, LADIES.
HELLO.
HI.
I'M RACHEL ZOE.
THE MISS FABULOUS RACHEL.
SHE IS
THE STYLIST OF THE STARS.
SHE--SHE'S BIG.
NOW I KNOW
THAT YOU GUYS MET WITH THE J's
AND YOU DISCUSSED
YOUR PERSONAL STYLE.
THEN YOU ATTENDED
THE GEN ART FASHION SHOW
AND YOU EACH CHOSE AN OUTFIT
THAT YOU THINK
REFLECTS YOUR PERSONAL STYLE.
YOU HAVE 15 MINUTES
TO DO YOUR HAIR, YOUR MAKEUP,
YOUR WARDROBE,
AND YOU GET A TINY BIT OF HELP
FROM OUR ACTUAL COVER GIRL
THAT'S HERE TODAY WITH US.
HEY, GIRLS.
LOOK WHO'S HERE.
I'M NAIMA, COVER GIRL.
IT WAS NICE TO SEE HER
'CAUSE SHE HAD WHAT WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
TODAY, YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR MAKEUP HELPS YOU
TO BRING WHO YOU ARE
AND THAT NATURAL BEAUTY
FROM THE INSIDE TO OUT.
WE HAVE HERE TODAY
THE QUEEN COLLECTION,
A BRAND-NEW LINE OF MAKEUP
DESIGNED BY QUEEN LATIFAH
AND COVER GIRL
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR.
THAT'S AWESOME
BECAUSE IT'S HARDER FOR ME
TO MATCH MY SKIN TONE.
I HAVE, LIKE, YELLOW TINTS,
I HAVE RED TINTS.
THE REST OF YOU GIRLS,
YOU'LL BE FINE
'CAUSE ALL COVER GIRL MAKEUP
IS GREAT.
THERE IS ONLY GONNA BE
ONE WINNER,
AND THE WINNER GETS
A $5,000 SHOPPING SPREE
WITH NANETTE LEPORE.
I AM NOT KIDDING.
SO YOU GUYS BETTER
ROCK IT OUT TODAY.
YES.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
YOUR 15 MINUTES BEGINS NOW.
♪♪♪
GIRLS, DON'T FOCUS
ON ONLY ONE THING.
YOU HAVE A VERY SMALL AMOUNT
OF TIME.
IF YOU'RE GOING
FOR A '40s OR '50s,
I WOULD KIND OF PALE YOU OUT
A LITTLE BIT, YOUR SKIN.
YOU MUST
ALTER YOURSELVES, GUYS.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
NO, I DON'T THINK I LIKE IT.
YEAH.
THIS IS THE QUEEN COLLECTION.
THINK YOUR CHEEKS ARE LIGHTER
THAN DOWN HERE,
BUT THAT GIVES AMAZING CONTOUR,
BY THE WAY.
I REALLY LIKE MY MAKEUP.
IT'S A FRESH LOOK.
IT'S NOT TOO HEAVY.
THINK ABOUT EVERYTHING--
YOUR LOOK, YOUR STANCE,
EVERYTHING.
LET'S TRY, LIKE, THIS COLOR.
BRING IT DOWN ONTO YOUR NECK,
SO LET THE COLOR GO--
OH, YEAH,
THAT IS MY COLOR.
YOU SEE?
YEAH.
FIVE, FOUR, THREE,
TWO, ONE.
DONE.
EVERYBODY, DONE.
I'M ALWAYS LOOKING FOR,
DO ALL THE ELEMENTS
OF THEIR LOOK TIE TOGETHER?
SO, JADE, YOUR MAKEUP
LOOKS FLAWLESS, VERY BOHEMIAN.
THE ONLY THING IS
WITH THOSE SANDALS,
INSTEAD OF A BOHEMIAN THING,
YOU'RE SORT OF CREATING
MORE OF A GLADIATOR.
LESLIE, THE PANTS--GREAT,
VERY SEXY, VERY FITTED.
THEY FIT YOU BEAUTIFULLY.
SARA, I LOVE HOW YOU WENT FOR
THE SORT OF ANDROGYNOUS LOOK,
BUT SOMEHOW TRY AND FIND
THAT MIDDLE AREA
BETWEEN WHAT'S APPROPRIATE
AND WHAT'S SEXY.
FOR THE RECORD, I WOULDN'T LEAVE
THE HOUSE IN THESE.
LIKE, I WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
GINA, YOU REALLY HAVE
THE RIGHT IDEA,
BUT IT ALMOST TAKES YOU
A LITTLE BIT TO MOD
BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH.
WENDY, IT IS COMPLETELY
SWEET-FACED J.LO,
BUT NEEDED TO TIGHTEN UP
THAT JACKET
TO SHOW OFF YOUR BODY.
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA SEE J.LO
WEARING CLOTHES
THAT ARE TOO BIG ON HER.
JOANIE, VERY RALPH LAUREN,
BUT YOU HAVE A LOT OF STUFF ON.
LESS IS MORE SOMETIMES.
DANIELLE, IF YOU ARE
GONNA DO BOOTS,
THEN WEAR A PAIR OF JEANS
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE LOOKING A LITTLE NAKED.
BROOKE, YOU ARE SORT OF
VERY VINTAGE.
THE ONLY THING IS
YOU'RE WEARING THESE BANGLES
THAT ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE
THE BOHEMIAN TREND.
KARI, THE BELT--BRIGHT YELLOW,
NOT SUCH A BOHEMIAN COLOR.
YOU WANT TO STAY MORE
TO THE EARTH TONES.
NNENNA, YOUR MAKEUP
LOOKS PERFECTLY FRESH,
AND I THINK THAT YOU REALLY
STAYED TRUE TO YOUR LOOK
AND SEEMED REALLY NATURAL
AND REALLY COMFORTABLE.
MOLLIE, YOU'RE
A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED
BETWEEN THE PUNK AND THE MOD,
AND WE WENT SAILOR ON THIS ONE.
IT STINKS I DIDN'T NAIL IT
'CAUSE I REALLY THOUGHT
THAT WAS MY COMPETITION
BECAUSE I AM PERSONAL STYLE.
FURONDA, YOU REALLY ACHIEVED
MOSTLY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE.
AND, TO ME,
THAT'S VERY, VERY IMPORTANT.
I'M DRESSED GREAT.
I'M REALLY FEELING IT TODAY.
OKAY, GIRLS,
SAY WHO THE WINNER IS TODAY,
AND SHE WINS $5,000
TO GO SHOPPING
AND GETS TO SHARE IT
WITH TWO OF YOU.
OKAY,
THE WINNER IS TODAY...
NNENNA.
YOU ROCKED IT OUT, WOMAN.
I THINK YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS, RIGHT?
YOU REALLY STAYED TRUE
TO YOUR STYLE.
AND I THINK THAT YOUR MAKEUP
TOTALLY FALLS INTO PLACE
WITH THE QUEEN COLLECTION.
YEP.
I WAS REALLY UPSET
ABOUT NOT WINNING THE CHALLENGE
BECAUSE I REALLY THOUGHT
I DID A GOOD JOB.
WELL, WHATEVER.
YOU GOT TO PICK
TWO OF YOUR FRIENDS.
I HAVE TO PICK
MY ROOMMATE GINA FIRST AND...
OKAY, JADE.
AT THE BEGINNING, GINA AND JADE
DIDN'T SEEM TO GET ALONG
TOO WELL.
HOPEFULLY, GOING
ON A SHOPPING SPREE,
I COULD GET THEM TO LEARN
SOMETHING MORE ABOUT EACH OTHER.
♪♪♪
HI, GUYS.
ARE WE EXCITED?
SHOPPING--WHOO!
THIS IS NICE.
AFRICAN QUEEN
AND MISS GINA, OH, YEAH.
I DON'T LIKE JADE,
BUT I DID MY THING,
AND THEN I WAS, LIKE,
GO AHEAD AND DO YOUR THING.
THIS IS AMAZING.
THE COLORS WITH YOUR HAIR
IS INCREDIBLE.
♪♪♪
EVERYONE'S REALLY, LIKE,
DISPLACED FROM THE HURRICANE.
I HAVE, LIKE, FAMILY
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
WE HAD, LIKE, 8 1/2 FEET
OF WATER IN THE HOUSE,
AND WE COULDN'T EVEN GET
IN THE KITCHEN.
YEAH?
EXCUSE ME, YO.
I NEED TO USE THE PHONE.
I HAVE NOT USED THE PHONE,
LIKE, SINCE I GOT HERE.
MAY I PLEASE USE THE PHONE?
I'M ON THE PHONE.
I HAD TO, LIKE, GET UP
AT 3:00 IN THE MORNING.
WELL, GIVE ME A TIME, PLEASE.
WHEN I GET OFF,
I'LL LET YOU KNOW.
I HADN'T TALKED TO MY FAMILY
SINCE MY MAKEOVER.
SO EVERYTHING WAS BUILDING UP
INSIDE OF ME.
I HAVEN'T USED THE PHONE AT ALL,
BUT EVERYBODY ELSE
HAS USED THE PHONE.
I DON'T
KNOW WHO I AM RIGHT NOW.
I'M LOST,
I NEED BALANCE.
YO, I'M TIRED OF STRUGGLING.
I FEEL LIKE I AM
THE UNDISCOVERED SUPERMODEL,
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'?
I LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY,
THE BELLY OF THE BEAST.
I'M TIRED OF THIS.
I'M IN
THE CORNER LAUGHING.
FURONDA'S LAUGHING,
WHICH IS JUST, LIKE,
ADDING FUEL TO THE FIRE.
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
THIS IS NOT "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP BEST FRIEND."
I WANT TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
BECAUSE I HAVE EVERYTHING
THAT IT TAKES TO BE THAT.
I KNOW I'M A THREAT.
I'M A STRONG-ASS WOMAN.
I'M A SOLDIER'S SISTER.
RECOGNIZE.
AND YOU'RE WEARING A CROWN
ON YOUR HEAD.
YOU LOOK RIDICULOUS.
YOU'RE OUT HERE IN YOUR--
OKAY, I'M LOSING IT.
OF COURSE, I'M IN MY PANTIES,
AND I LOOK DAMN GOOD.
BROKE-ASS CROWN--
THEY AIN'T EVEN REAL DIAMONDS.
GOOD-BYE, J.LO,
GOOD-BYE, J.LO.
JADE JUST STARTED SCREAMING
AT FURONDA
ABOUT HER BEING A DIVA
AND STARTED YELLING AT WENDY
ABOUT BEING ON THE PHONE
TOO LONG
AND JUST KIND OF LOST IT.
DAMN IT,
SHE WOKE ME UP.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO BRING SOMEBODY ELSE DOWN
TO BRING YOURSELF UP, YOU KNOW?
EXACTLY.
THESE GIRLS
ARE HORRIBLE, MOM.
THEY'RE TRYING
TO CORRUPT ME, MOM.
THE PEROXIDE'S
MESSING WITH HER BRAIN.
AT FIRST, I THOUGHT
FURONDA'S LITTLE RULES
WERE STUPID,
BUT WE JUST STICK TO THEM.
HERE'S WHAT I WAS TRYING
TO AVOID, YOU KNOW.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
"DON'T BLOW YOUR COVER.
TYRA."
OOH!
YAY!
YEAH!
I'M READY FOR ANOTHER CHANCE,
FOR SOMETHING THAT CAN HELP ME
TO PROVE MYSELF AND SHOW THAT I
REALLY WANT TO BE HERE.
WE WERE JUST WALKING
TO THIS BIG WAREHOUSE BUILDING,
AND WE'RE NOT REALLY SURE
WHAT'S GOING ON.
(shivers)
JAY MANUEL
WAS STANDING THERE,
AND I SEE ICE CRYSTALS,
AN ICE WALL,
AND THERE'S SNOW ON THE GROUND.
AND I'M JUST, LIKE, OH, GOD
OH, JEEZ, NO.
GOOD MORNING,
HOW ARE YA?
GOOD MORNING.
TODAY'S SHOOT
IS ON THIS AMAZING SET
MADE OF ICE,
AND YOU'LL EACH BE SHOT
AS IF IT'S A MAGAZINE COVER.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU GIRLS
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY,
RICHARD.
HE IS A VERY TALENTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
RICHARD, HERE ARE
YOUR LITTLE POPSICLES.
WOW,
WELCOME TO THE FREEZER.
I JUST WANT YOU TO IMAGINE
THAT YOU'RE SOMEWHERE WARM.
IT'S HELLA COLD.
I'M SHAKING
LIKE A LITTLE CHIHUAHUA.
LET'S HEAD OUT
TO HAIR, MAKEUP.
♪♪♪
THIS IS MY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
WITH MY NEW, CRAZY LOOK,
AND I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT EXACTLY
I SHOULD BE DOING WITH IT.
GORGEOUS.
WOW.
CHIN DOWN 'CAUSE THAT DOES NOT
LOOK PRETTY.
JUST LIKE THAT,
DON'T EVEN THINK OF MOVING.
GOOD.
I THINK SARA DOESN'T REALIZE
THAT WHEN YOU LEAVE
YOUR MOUTH HANGING OPEN
FOR THE WHOLE PHOTO SHOOT,
IT'S NOT REALLY ATTRACTIVE.
I JUST FELT THAT WHOOSH
OF COLD AIR,
BUT I'M THINKING,
OH, MAYBE JUST THINK
ABOUT THE DESERT
AND HOW HOT IT IS.
♪♪♪
HERE, PASS THIS TISSUE
TO HER, PLEASE.
WHOO.
NOW I WANT YOU
TO FEEL THIS ENVIRONMENT.
OH!
MOTHER OF GOD,
IT'S COLD!
OKAY, YEAH, WE KNOW.
NNENNA WAS JUST TOTALLY
THROWN INTO SHOCK BY WALKING
INTO THIS COLD ENVIRONMENT,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE GOT--
ON HER FACE,
IN HER BODY LANGUAGE--SHOCK.
WE GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA, GOOD JOB.
SHE WANTS TO GET OUT OF HERE
SO FAST.
♪♪♪
FREEZE THAT,
THAT'S GREAT.
DON'T MOVE.
MOLLIE SUE HAS
A VERY COOL LOOK,
BUT I WANT TO SEE
MORE OF A RANGE OF EMOTION
OUT OF HER.
DANIELLE'S ON SET.
THESE SHOTS ARE REALLY GOOD,
AND THEN JUST
EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE,
THEY GET A LITTLE HO-HUMMY.
SO KEEP IT CLEAN.
♪♪♪
JOANIE, IT'S LOOKING
A LITTLE, LIKE, PRINCESS-Y
AND I NEED MORE FASHION-Y.
OKAY, YOUR KNEES
ARE TOO TOUCHY RIGHT NOW.
GET A LITTLE MORE ASYMMETRY
TO IT.
I KNOW YOU'RE FROM NEW ORLEANS,
WHERE IT'S TYPICALLY
A LITTLE WARMER.
BUT REMEMBER MY COMMENT
LAST PHOTO SHOOT.
IT GOT A LITTLE VACANT
IN THE FACE.
AND IF YOU'RE NOT THINKING IT
AND YOU'RE NOT FEELING IT--
YOU'RE NOT BEING FIERCE--
IT'S NOT GONNA LOOK LIKE THAT
IN THE PICTURE.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE ON AN ADVENTURE.
YOU'RE WALKING THROUGH,
A LITTLE MORE FEELING.
SHE'S LOOKING A LITTLE
LIKE A FRIGHTENED BIRD.
I JUST NEED SOMETHING
A LITTLE STRONGER,
A LITTLE MORE DYNAMIC.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WENDY.
I FEEL
LIKE WENDY'S STATE OF MIND
READS ON HER FACE.
WHEN WENDY WALKS ONTO MY SET,
I SEE THE WEIGHT OF THE WORLD
ON HER SHOULDERS.
MY FEET ARE OKAY.
IT'S MY HANDS
THAT ARE REALLY BAD.
YOU'RE DOING BETTER
THAN I DID.
I COULDN'T WALK.
SITTING WAS THE WORST
'CAUSE, LIKE,
YOU'RE MELTING THE SEAT
AND YOU'RE, LIKE, SLIDING,
AND, YOU KNOW.
IT'S CRAZY, DUDE.
♪♪♪
CAN WE UNCROSS THE LEGS?
IT'S, LIKE, HIT-OR-MISS.
SOMETIMES, I GET
TOWARDS FASHION,
AND SOMETIMES SHE ENDS UP
PLAYING A PLAYMATE.
♪♪♪
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU.
NICE MEETING YOU.
♪♪♪
LESLIE, JUST FORGET
THAT YOU'RE COLD
'CAUSE I'M STARTING TO SEE YOU
FREEZING UP IN THE FACE.
♪♪♪
I JUST LOVE HOW YOU GUYS--
YOU GUYS ARE, LIKE, BEAUTIFUL
AND, LIKE, ELEGANT.
JADE--SHE'S MISS CONFIDENT,
YOU KNOW.
SHE'S MISS I-GOT-EVERYTHING-
IN-THE-BAG,
BUT SHE'S SHOWING THAT SHE'S NOT
SO TOUGH, AFTER ALL.
GINA, YOU LOOK FROZEN.
THE FIRST 50 FRAMES
THAT GINA SHOT
WERE JUST USELESS TO ME.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHAT I'M DOING WRONG.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
AS OPPOSED TO, LIKE, NAILING IT.
GIVE ME THE JAY ATTITUDE.
LAST FRAME.
GORGEOUS, NICE.
THERE YOU GO.
♪♪♪
OH, THAT'S PRETTY,
KIND OF LIKE
GETTING MORE SLINKY,
FALL INTO THE MOMENT.
BROOKE IS VERY GOOD
AT EXUDING SEX APPEAL
WITHOUT IT LOOKING SLEAZY.
♪♪♪
I DIDN'T FEEL BEAUTIFUL
WITH MY MAKEUP.
I COULDN'T REALLY DO MUCH
BUT JUST STAND THERE
IN A BATHING SUIT,
HALF-ASS NAKED.
A LITTLE LESS SEVERE.
GOOD, BEAUTIFUL, GOOD.
A LITTLE HAPPY,
A LITTLE MORE.
IT'S NOT A SQUINT,
IT'S A SMILE--
REAL SMILE, NOT COLD.
THAT'S A SMILE?
UGH.
MY EYES ARE JUST DIFFERENT.
JADE TRULY WAS THE EPITOME
OF AN ICE PRINCESS TODAY
BECAUSE SHE WAS JUST ICY
IN THE FACE.
I WANT TO SEE FURONDA.
I WANT TO
SEE MISS DIVA.
I WANT TO SEE
WHAT SHE'S GONNA ROCK.
I HAD ANOTHER CHANCE,
MY LAST CHANCE.
I GOT TO AMP THIS UP,
LIKE, 1,000%.
♪♪♪
I CANNOT GO HOME.
HEY, FURONDA,
THIS IS ALREADY MORE SHOTS
THAN YOUR WHOLE LAST SHOOT.
SHOW THAT LENGTH YOU'VE GOT.
WATCH THAT CHIN, THOUGH.
FURONDA LET GO
IN THIS PHOTO SHOOT TODAY.
THEREFORE, FURONDA'S PERFORMANCE
WAS A LOT BETTER
THAN HER LAST PHOTO SHOOT.
FURONDA ISN'T A BIG CONCERN
TO ME
BECAUSE SHE DID REALLY BAD.
YOU WERE ALL, LIKE, THIS.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL,
I THOUGHT IT WAS PRETTY.
WE'LL SEE HOW IT TURNS OUT.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
TYRA."
I KNOW THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
FOR ME TO BE STANDING
ON THAT DAIS.
IT'S POSSIBLE FOR ANY ONE OF US
TO BE GOING HOME.
♪♪♪
YOU'VE ALL HAD
SOME BEAUTIFUL MAKEOVERS,
AND I CAN SEE THE RESULTS,
WHICH I'M VERY PROUD OF.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME
IN THIS JUDGING ROOM.
AND AT THE END OF THIS EVENING,
ONE OF YOU WILL BE GOING HOME.
YOU KNOW
ABOUT OUR FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH A TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY--
FORD MODELS--
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER GILLES BENSIMON
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES VERY WELL.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
MR. NIGEL BARKER.
HELLO, LADIES,
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.
LEGENDARY RUNWAY COACH
MISS J. ALEXANDER.
WELL, 1 DOWN, 11 MORE TO GO.
AND FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND MISS TWIGGY.
HELLO, LADIES.
AND, OF COURSE,
OUR GUEST JUDGE FOR THE WEEK
MISS RACHEL ZOE.
RACHEL WAS THE STYLIST
THAT HELPED YOU ALL THIS WEEK.
THIS WEEK, YOU LEARNED
ABOUT HOW TO POSE FOR A COVER
OF A MAGAZINE.
THERE'S A CERTAIN CONNECTION
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
TO MAKE THAT PERSON
WALKING BY THAT NEWSSTAND
BUY THAT MAGAZINE.
AND WHAT BETTER WAY
TO SELL A MAGAZINE
THAN TO HAVE YOUR NAME
ON THAT COVER?
LET'S START WITH DANIELLE.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO POSE
IN THE FREEZING COLD
AND STILL SELL A COVER.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
DANIELLE, YOU HAVE
A COMMANDING PRESENCE.
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO, THOUGH,
IF YOU COME TO JUDGING
WITH YOUR HAIR LIKE THIS AGAIN,
DON'T WEAR IT ON ONE SIDE.
GO UPSIDE-DOWN
AND SCRUNCH YOUR HAIR,
YOU KNOW, THE WHITE GIRL THING.
THERE YOU GO.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO DO THAT WITH MY HAIR
AND NEVER HAD IT.
ALL RIGHTY, NEXT IS KARI.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD
TO BE FREEZING COLD.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
LAST WEEK,
YOU WERE VERY DOLLISH
AND THIS COVER SHOWS ME
THAT YOU CAN GO THE OTHER WAY,
BE VERY SEXY.
AND WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM
IS THAT YOU'RE NOT AFRAID
TO DO AN UGLY MOVE
BECAUSE AN UGLY MOVE
CAN SOMETIMES CROPPED
TURN INTO...
YOU KNOW, SO KEEP DOING THAT.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS LESLIE.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
THIS DEFINITELY
SORT OF QUALIFIES YOU
FOR THE MEN'S MAGAZINES.
YEAH.
YOU HAVE TO WORK
TOTALLY AGAINST THAT.
MORE ODD ANGLES.
THINK MORE HUNCHED,
THINK MORE MASCULINE.
OKAY.
UP NEXT IS MOLLIE SUE.
YOU ARE, LIKE, MY FANTASY GIRL
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS SHORT HAIR.
BUT SINCE YOU ARE
ONE OF THE SHORTEST GIRLS HERE,
YOU SHOULD NEVER COME TO JUDGING
WITHOUT HEELS.
EVER.
YOU NEED TO ROLL OUT A 7
AND STAND UP A 10.
ALL RIGHTY.
SO LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
IT LOOKS VERY EUROPEAN.
IT'S DEFINITELY
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
IT'S VERY EDGY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UP NEXT IS WENDY.
ALL RIGHTY.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR A WENDY COVER.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
NOT BAD.
I LOVE THE MOTION
OF THE BODY.
BUT IT'S AN ACTRESS,
IT'S NOT A MODEL.
YOUR POSE
IS WAY TOO SAFE.
WITH YOUR HAIR, YOU'VE GOT
A LOT OF VOLUME TO IT,
MAKING YOUR SHOULDERS
LOOK NOT AS WIDE, EVEN NOW.
I WANT YOU SLICKED BACK
IN A TIGHT BUN.
ARE WE HAVING
A "FLASHDANCE" MOMENT?
I FEEL LIKE SHE SHOULD RIP
HER SHIRT DOWN--EXACTLY.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK YOU LOOK STUNNING
NOW.
OKAY.
I KNOW
WITH HURRICANE KATRINA,
YOU LOST EVERYTHING.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S CARRYING
INTO THIS COMPETITION?
I TRY REALLY HARD
TO NOT EVEN THINK ABOUT IT,
JUST FOCUS ON WHAT I'M HERE FOR.
OKAY.
THANKS, WENDY.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD
TO BE FREEZING COLD.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
I THINK IT LOOKS
VERY HIGH-FASHION.
YOUR SHOULDERS ARE WONDERFUL.
YOUR POSE IS WAY TOO SAFE.
IT'S NOT TAKING US
ANYWHERE ELSE,
OTHER THAN THE OBVIOUS.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE, THANKS.
SARA, YOUR TURN.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
YOU ARE ONE OF THE GIRLS
THAT HAS REALLY JUMPED OUT
TO ME,
AND YOUR PHOTOGRAPH IS, FOR ME,
VERY DISAPPOINTING.
I DON'T THINK
YOU ARE ACTUALLY COMFORTABLE
WITH YOUR MAKEOVER
'CAUSE YOU'VE GOT
THAT PRETTINESS,
YOU'VE GOT THE BODY.
WORK THE LOOK.
ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
I LOVE THE WAY YOU STAND,
I LOVE THE WAY YOU WALK.
I LIKE THE BROKEN-DOWN
CZAR LOOK.
BUT CAN SHE PULL IT OFF
IN THE PICTURE?
LET'S SEE.
AND YOU'RE NOT
SORT OF CLASSICALLY PRETTY.
WHAT YOU ARE
IS SORT OF WRONG,
BUT THAT WRONG IS SO RIGHT.
BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT CONVENTIONALLY PRETTY,
THAT COULD BE YOUR FORTUNE.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT IS FURONDA.
ALL RIGHT, FURONDA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
FURONDA, YOU NEED
TO BE A PRESENCE,
IN JUDGING AND ON A COVER.
'CAUSE, OBVIOUSLY,
YOU'RE VERY SHY.
SHE AIN'T SHY.
YOU DON'T THINK SHE'S SHY?
AT ALL.
IT'S, LIKE,
POCAHONTAS ICE PRINCESS,
SO I'M KIND OF LOVING THAT.
AND I'M LOOKING
THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I WAS ACTUALLY VERY PROUD
OF YOU.
IT WAS A TOTALLY DIFFERENT GIRL
THAN THE BALD-HEADED GIRL
I SAW LAST WEEK.
THANKS, FURONDA.
NEXT IS GINA.
ALL RIGHT, GINA,
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID
IN YOUR PHOTO.
YOU NEED TO LEARN
ALL ABOUT YOUR ANGLES
AND REALLY WORK
YOUR BEAUTIFUL FACE.
I THINK
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A COVER,
BUT I DO THINK
IT'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
ALL RIGHT, GINA.
NEXT IS NNENNA.
YOU'RE JUST ON A ROLL,
MISS LADY.
YOU WON
THE CHALLENGE THIS WEEK.
AGAIN, CONGRATULATIONS.
IT WAS ABOUT EVOKING
PERSONAL STYLE,
AND YOU WERE
THE AFRICAN PRINCESS.
AND YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
OOH, GIRL, YOU COULD PUT
A CHILL ON A POPSICLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THIS PHOTOGRAPH,
THE BEAUTIFUL COMPLEXITY
YOU HAVE--
THIS IS A GREAT
FASHION-FORWARD SHOT.
EVERY NOW AND THEN,
YOU WERE A LITTLE AWKWARD.
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW TO WORK THE STRENGTH
OF YOUR FACE,
SO YOU GET A LITTLE...
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, NNENNA.
LAST,
BUT NOT LEAST, JADE.
YOU SCARED ME A LITTLE BIT
WHEN YOU COME OUT
'CAUSE YOU'RE VERY AGGRESSIVE.
JADE, ARE YOU ANGRY?
I'M HAVING
A LITTLE DIFFICULT TIME
IN THE HOUSE
WITH SOME OF THE GIRLS,
AND I'M GETTING A LITTLE BIT
OF PROBLEMS
WITH SOME OF THE GIRLS.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
I KNOW
THAT I'M A BIG THREAT, I FEEL,
IN THE HOUSE
'CAUSE I AM--
I HAVE THE MOST DRAMATIC
TRANSFORMATION, I FEEL.
IT'S SUCH A TRANSITION.
YEAH, BUT WE'VE BEEN DOING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
FOR SIX CYCLES
AND HAD EVEN BIGGER TRANSITIONS
THAN YOURS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY,
THIS IS JUDGING.
OF COURSE.
LEAVE YOUR BAGGAGE BEHIND.
COME HERE TO WIN THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, JADE, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU HAD TO SELL
THE JADE COVER.
NOW WHY PROFILE?
I JUST DON'T THINK
YOU CAN DO A COVER SHOT
AND NOT LOOK AT THE CAMERA.
I MEAN, IT JUST
DOESN'T WORK.
JAY MANUAL SAID
THAT YOU COMPLAIN
THAT YOU CAN'T WORK YOUR EYES
BECAUSE THEY ARE SLANTY
AND SMALL.
IT WAS ALSO, I THINK,
THE EYE MAKEUP, AS WELL.
IT WAS VERY--'CAUSE--
YOU JUST
CAN'T DO ALL THIS.
YOU CAN'T BITCH
ABOUT WHAT YOU HAD DONE
AND THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON.
THIS IS WHAT MODELING
IS ABOUT.
WHEN YOU'RE A NEW MODEL
UP UNTIL WHEN YOU'RE
CINDY CRAWFORD LEVEL,
THEY DON'T DO STUFF
THAT LOOKS GOOD ON YOU.
THE BUYER NEEDS TO SEE
THIS EYE SHADOW.
THEY NEED TO SEE THESE CLOTHES.
SO IT'S UP TO YOU AS A MODEL
TO MAKE THAT AMAZING.
OKAY.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND AFTER THAT,
I'LL CALL YOU BACK,
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU IS GOING HOME.
NNENNA.
NNENNA'S GOT CONFIDENCE.
SHE HAS SORT OF
THAT QUIET CONFIDENCE,
SHE'S SUBTLE.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL SMILE.
I LOVE HER.
I THINK SHE HAS SUCH A SPIRIT
AND A NATURAL WAY ABOUT HER.
GINA.
I SEE A RATHER PRETTY GIRL
WITH BEAUTIFUL CHEEKBONES.
I DON'T SEE A MODEL.
GINA'S WEAKNESSES
ARE WHEN SHE'S IN PERSON.
I THINK SHE LOOKS CONFUSED
AND DAZED,
AND SHE'S NOT REALLY WITH US.
BROOKE.
I CAN'T KEEP MY EYES
OFF BROOKE
WHEN SHE'S STANDING IN THE LINE.
I THINK WITH THESE FEATURES,
THERE'S NO WAY SHE'S OUT.
WITH THAT POUT,
SHE COULD NEVER BE OUT.
NO WAY.
SARA.
I FEEL LIKE SHE'S STILL IN THAT
MOMENT OF, OH, MY GOD.
I WAS STILL SO TALL AND GAWKY
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER.
SHE HAS NO CONNECTION
WITH THE CAMERA,
BUT SHE'S GOT A GREAT LOOK.
JOANIE.
JOANIE MIGHT BE PRETTY
WITH HER MOUTH SHUT.
AS SOON AS SHE OPENS HER MOUTH,
I'M SORRY, BUT THAT TOOTH--
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
1-800-SMILE,
AND THAT CAN BE DONE, CHILD.
WENDY.
I DIDN'T GET WENDY LAST WEEK,
AND WHEN SHE CAME OUT TODAY,
I DIDN'T REALLY GET HER.
SHE'S GOT THE BONE STRUCTURE,
BEAUTIFUL PROFILE.
SHE HAS TO LEARN TO WORK
WITH IT.
I HONESTLY DON'T SEE MODEL.
LESLIE.
I'M NOT SURE
THIS IS QUIET FASHION.
IT'S MORE LIKE
A MAN'S MAGAZINE PHOTO.
HER BALD PHOTO--
THAT WASN'T "MAXIM"-Y
OR TOO MAN MAGAZINE-Y?
SHE JUST NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE HECK FASHION IS.
MOLLIE SUE.
MOLLIE WHO?
SHE DOESN'T TAKE MY BREATH
AWAY WHEN I LOOK AT HER,
BUT I THINK THE SHORT HAIRCUT
IS GREAT.
FURONDA.
I'M A BIG FAN OF FURONDA.
I COULD SEE HER STRUTTING
EVERY RUNWAY IN EUROPE.
FURONDA'S GONE-DA FOR ME,
'CAUSE QUITE FRANKLY,
THIS IS LIKE E.T. WITH A WIG ON.
KARI.
SHE'S A BARBIE DOLL,
BUT NOT A TOP FASHION MODEL,
AND THEN SHE DID
THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
SO I'D LIKE TO WATCH HER
SOME MORE.
DANIELLE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A MODEL.
I LOVE HER.
DANIELLE REMINDS ME
OF THE GIRLS THAT I GREW
UP WITH IN INGLEWOOD--
LIKE, "YO, YOU WANT
TO GO HOP-SCOTCHING?
I'M FIRST.
OH, NO, YOU DIDN'T, TYRA"--
JUST LIKE THAT KIND OF ENERGY,
WHERE YOU THINK THEY'RE, LIKE,
ANGRY, BUT REALLY,
IT'S NOT REALLY ANGRY,
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT IS.
THAT'S WHAT SHE REMINDS ME OF.
JADE.
SHE'S SCARY SPICE TO ME.
I DON'T LIKE HER ARROGANCE,
AND I DON'T LIKE
THAT PHOTOGRAPH.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD FADE
WITH JADE,
BUT KIND OF KNOCK
SOME OF THAT ARROGANCE
OUT OF HER, I THINK.
JADE JUST
NEEDS TO GET LAID.
12 LOVELY GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 11 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE 11 PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE YOUNG WOMEN
THAT WILL STILL
BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
BROOKE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
DANIELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
NNENNA.
KARI.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
FURONDA.
YOU WERE AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE PACK.
YOUR PHOTO LAST WEEK WAS...
BUT THIS--
LOOK AT YOUR EYES,
HOW THEY CONNECT.
THAT'S A MODEL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
GINA.
(imitates southern accent)
MISS MOLLIE SUE.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE SAYING
HER NAME LIKE THAT.
MY NAME IS TYRA LYNNE.
(normal voice)
CONGRATULATIONS.
LESLIE.
SARA.
SARA, YOU HAVE THE JUDGES
ALL CONFUSED AND JUST...
SO YOU HAVE A LOT TO PROVE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JOANIE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL JADE AND WENDY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
TWO BEAUTIFUL,
INTERESTING WOMEN
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY PACK HER BAGS
AND GO HOME.
WENDY, THE JUDGES SEE A MODEL
IN PERSON,
BUT FOR TWO WEEKS IN A ROW,
THEY HAVE BEEN
LESS THAN IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR PHOTOS.
SO WHAT THE JUDGES SEE RIGHT NOW
IS A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN THAT POTENTIAL
PUT INTO A PHOTO.
JADE, YOU'RE STANDING HERE
BECAUSE THE JUDGES THINK
THAT YOU ARE FULL OF EXCUSES,
THAT YOU DON'T TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOUR ACTIONS.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
JADE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE THINK THE ARROGANCE
IS ACTUALLY INSECURITY,
BUT WE FEEL YOU HAVE POTENTIAL
IF YOU CAN SHOW US
THE REAL JADE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
I THINK I WAS
A LITTLE SHOCKED
WHEN TYRA DELIVERED THE NEWS
THAT I WOULD BE GOING HOME.
I DON'T THINK
THAT I WAS REALLY
EXPECTING THAT.
I THINK MY FAMILY
WILL BE PROUD OF ME
THAT I'VE MADE IT THIS FAR.
I DON'T LOOK AT IT
AS THIS IS THE END,
I BELIEVE, FOR ME.
AND I'D REALLY LIKE
TO THINK OF IT
AS ONLY THE BEGINNING.
(sniffs)
♪♪♪
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
IT'S TIME TO WALK THE WALK
WITH MISS J.
TIPPY-TUMBLES.
HEY, YOU ALMOST LOOK CRAZY.
GINA GETS NEEDY
WITH DANIELLE.
YOU'RE WAITING
TO TAKE A SHOWER?
YEP.
CAN I WATCH YOU?
I'M FOLLOWING YOU.
AND THE GIRLS
GET AN UNWELCOME VISITOR
ON THE RUNWAY.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
SHARE THESE.
GO!